look it's happened to all of us you're
minding your own business playing your
game and suddenly you get tricked fooled
bamboozled but you and I were average
players when the pros get duke that's
another story entirely which is why
today we want to run down our top ten
favorite moments where the pros got
tricked but before we get to that I want
to make sure to tell you guys about the
don't at me and story of podcast they're
out now and you can find them wherever
you download great podcast anyway let's
get into it
these are the top 10 bamboozles in
esports there are several ways that you
can be bamboozled in csgo but one of the
worst is getting tricked by a creative
beat flash Nitro does have a most often
under smoke so it could be really rough
for single tanks to get through this
[Applause]
that's why number 10 and our list isn't
one particular moment but an O Maj for
the many times we've seen pros get
absolutely bamboozled by the different
things thrown their way one more player
close on the site yum needs to take down
JK s he's got time Oh what the Orcas fun
JK yes going for the simple play throws
his orb away goes for the pistol and
wins the round or just thought what the
[ __ ] when facing an enemy head-on
I knew they're gonna need to get this
first kill here
I think there may be a distraction get
control wrap some kailu do they just
throw the bomb to to bait our face kind
of something I really like make Carrigan
singlet what the hell is going on coming
in at number nine is one of the most
innovative plays the professional
overwatch has ever seen if you don't
know about met Athena's am a wall flank
on dorado that surprised the lunatic hi
and left viewers at home with their jaws
dropped well you will now ok this is
gonna be a long link actually very long
the payload is not over there okay
they're gonna try and take the high
ground up a boost on top of the high
ground coming down Lucic is no idea
they're coming from this angle don't go
back up though they had a hunch that
something was going on they get walled
off during the Rhinehart charge though
grandpa'll time Lucic I'm trying to hold
Nana boo set both Reinhardt's libero
firing away with those right clicks and
they find them sometimes events have
been Athena get the kills they needed
that is actually brilliant I mean just
fantastic use so been Athena had a
couple of tricks going for them there
and one of them works this is my player
st. manages to reposition how do you
find now it isn't uncommon to see
players getting boosted to higher ground
with maze wall but this was the first
time it was ever used as a strategic
flank to get behind enemy lines and wipe
them out entirely
needless to say lunatic I did not see it
coming
Arlis just wouldn't be complete without
clg's peekaboo play from the 2016 na LCS
spring semi-finals which is why it's
coming in at number eight with the
series tied up at two games apiece
both teams found themselves in a
winner-takes-all scenario so after a
close teamfight that saw CLG come out on
top darshan and who he casted a cheeky
double teleport down mid lane that not
only fooled the enemy but also the
caster the result a surprise that
ultimately ones in the series he can't
do some big damage eyes on him in these
fights for sure and piglet is definitely
a hyper carry mode right now but darshan
wants to kill him that's a little baby
only thought it was one he had to have
only thought it was one TP and he could
exit that with a caliber net it is
nearly impossible to tell when two
people are coming in on the same ward
you get to see the doís lights up to
like a fraction of a second and I do not
know a person on this earth who can read
that line it is impossible at the RLC s
season three grand finals and our G met
tournament favorites flipside tactics to
the upper bracket semi finals for what
was supposed to be a one-sided match but
it was there that Garrett G pulled off
one of the greatest plays in the game's
history as he bamboozled the hell out of
both defenders to strut down the pitch
for an easy goal Hartman wraps it around
Garrett G moves up the screen play
[Applause]
baby just stop
[Applause]
three zero similar to number ten our
number six entry cannot be boiled down
to a single moment but rather it's the
many times we've seen csgo players get
bamboozled by a fake bomb plant with
strategy in 200 IQ plays being a
fundamental part of the game it's
moments like these that make watching
csgo just so damn entertaining don't
believe us just take a look for yourself
but there we have a kid miss Ollie's try
get a little bit further than wanted and
this is all just a clever ruse this is a
gorgeous rose as well look at this the
bombs gonna be planted down a great
position I think they've got an they're
gonna hear this they've got to hear this
this wants to stay alive now this is
that some kind of sick but they still
won't know it days
that would have been that do they
realize realized and they done have much
time that father
if happy can slow them down will do
anything and that's a problem because
here comes to push it into the default
sign there goes the rotation but the
bombs going to be alone on the a side
and so x7 centipoid I mean if you just
win the round here that's great the
cycads has got a lot of work on his
hands but he's been delivering so far so
to pick up one and now they're gonna
realize strats at the major and you
believe it they've been solder dummy
they've been solder fakes the cheap lock
off the bombs on the a bombs line the
pistol is with heads there is no doubt
that you need to have a big brain to
play dota2 at the highest level which
was exactly my miracles Great Escape had
to make an appearance on this list as he
evades Alliance in more ways than one
when a limp caught miracle teleporting
away with just a sliver of a health left
his death appeared to be a foregone
conclusion
but miracle had other plans using Manta
illusion miracle cloned himself as he
disappeared into the tree line before
blinking away in milliseconds
just before warlocks ultimate landed and
oh yeah he also killed the courier for
good measure what a god it's keeping
much of a man alive limb called quite
sealed the deal of turn suppose miracle
but vehicles have to blink ow oh he
missed cuz the evasion yet she missed
miracle with that auto-attack miracle
might actually can caught anyway the
right clicks flips gotta get him or some
answer that miracle Hodge about with a
shitty cup oh oh my god
no he's gonna get the courier Oh what
what is happening another relocating it
to cheer him up he doesn't that voice
please you travel up again cop here I
believe
that was oh okay eyes I mean you can't
write that stuff any better really
that's what Sally cookie crumbles
met in the world of miracle all right
before you leave a comment yes we're
gonna show you the Olaf boost again and
yes we made our interns pull it up for
the millionth time but look there's just
no denying that the boost meissner's
play is one of the most shocking things
ever witnessed and csgo and by now you
know the story after getting stomped by
ldlc in the first half of the game
fnatic decided to pull out a last ditch
boo strategy that turns their enemies
into sitting ducks in a winner-take-all
do-or-die scenario prettiest and the
game of oh do they have a width roost
going on currently yes this is beautiful
Drew's as well he sees them now they're
straight headshot they have no idea
Smith's looking confused and dazed and
it's gonna be a
you'll see they just lost around to it
and they they still have no sure that
getting fired it is rainy down death
dermabond round after round the boost to
work to a tee and though it was deemed
illegal after the matter the Olaf loose
will forever be a staple in eSports
history and the score eSports top 10
lists taking the number 3 spot on our
list is a 2000 IQ team play for the ages
a play that onco down is one of the best
in eSports history it's the LA
gladiators surprising everyone on day
one of the first ever o WL playoffs so
just sit back relax and let Ober take
you through this plays genius looks
riddle miss ah here I feel like more
recently we're not asking what silk
thread can do anymore or what kind of
asking what he can't so many different
euros that he can sort of bring out
pasta was very effective
ok I like this for the Gladius this is
this is cheap you know try to circle
around the Spitfire what are you to Rupp
this a little bit yeah where are you
going
where are you oh this is so nice Chum
postilion small so he's waiting here we
can sort of walk out what I'll try doing
I think he's gonna either he's gonna
either switch to Widowmaker
the plants but not this one flank from
the gladiators and let loose the widow
at just the right time an MLG Dallas
2011 we were treated to one of the most
infamous moments in Starcraft history
that's right we're talking about Hutt's
masterful plan that fooled the hell out
of his biggest rival at the time a drunk
after seeing a massive army of void rays
at Huck's command is Rafi maturely quit
the game thinking that he just had no
chance of beating up now out on the
field and it looks like there's some
certainly soon a counter-attack
in the main the void Ray's all
hallucinations doing absolutely no
damage whatsoever there's to blink up
onto the high ground just trying to
distract aedra those hallucinating void
rays almost fully charged wheat and
Hydra left the game oh oh my goodness
Edra deployed arrays weren't real
they were hallucinations and after the
fact puck made sure that Ian knew they
were fake when I first played brood war
someone said wouldn't it be funny if you
hallucinate as a bunch of carriers and
your opponent just left that is what we
just saw here at MLG topping off our
list is a devious little play from no
tidehunter that word eg into a death
trap
during the dota 2 Dreamhack winter grand
finals admiralbulldog sacrificed his
life into Rosh pit to replicate a failed
kill baiting eg towards him for a
bamboozle that left everyone speechless
if you're lucky to pull if you're
looking to do anything else you've got
to keep your eyes open for that one and
wow admiralbulldog giving a freebie and
here we go haha
game is on bait is lame there's a small
blood patch where Admiral bullet trap
and
it's actually trapped because they came
to check for it now the stun bigger then
I'm gonna bring it down
oh my games now on the beat is lips
wheeze they pull something out of the
bag and feet is gonna go down as well oh
I'm some water stop what a strategy
coming out from eternal MD the Prophet
fate he doesn't lose any gold anything
by suiciding corrosion it's a pure obey
he spent all his gold on starting on him
and no China just come right out get two
kills right up the back no one has ever
done that no one's ever done that in the
history of dota
alright guys that's our list you think
we got bamboozled didn't miss something
well make sure to let us know in the
comments below don't forget to like the
video subscribe to the channel and of
course we'll see you next week thanks
for watching if you want more content
like this hit the sub button and ring
that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]